hey everyone I just wanted to say a
quick thank you to all our good humans
across the globe who purchased an item
from our surface-level collection or
actually almost sold out so if you're
interested in checking it out I would go
soon I am wearing a human good crewneck
myself while in quarantine since it's
been a bit chilly and I have found to be
very warm and comforting I just wanted
to say thank you again for believing in
our message for finding ways to practice
empathy in our day to day lives and I
hope you all stay safe and if you are
interested in our items stick around to
the end of the video and we'll give you
a link otherwise enjoy the video
in my school a girl wanted to commit
suicide a lot of people including myself
were laughing because we thought that
she was joking she ended up doing it I
regret it
all my friends are very smart I came
from a gifted program in middle school
and ended up failing multiple classes in
the past three years I've managed to
hide this from my parents only one
person knows about my failed suicide
attempts stemming from my academic
problems and the constant waiting for my
parents I'm really struggling to find my
identity and it feels as though everyone
around me already knows there's almost
like I'll never find who I really am my
friends all think that I'm happy 24/7
yeah I am miserable every minute of
every day I feel like an outsider I
always make sure they are okay yeah no
one asked me if I am I feel as though I
can't talk to my friends they wouldn't
understand
but they are the only people that I have
I used to listen to my parents fight
every day when they thought I was asleep
this made it hard for me to do things
with my parents because I knew that they
were fighting yeah I grew up with both
my parents and I was always like
embarrassed of that because a lot of the
people that were in my school or my
neighborhood didn't have both parents
but my parents fought a lot I resented
my father for his anger and his
frustration I resented my mother for
being sick and all of our money going
towards health care and and as a family
you don't talk about often because it's
not you're like this is nobody's
business what we're arguing about we're
good we're happy family look at all
these pictures look at us you know but
it does it does affect you and it
doesn't make it difficult
I am extremely self-conscious about my
looks there has been a time where I felt
so ugly I considered ending my life
because I thought if I wasn't pretty
there was no reason to be here this
would have been my confession four years
ago not many people know but I have
attempted suicide four times in my life
because of the mental health issues that
I have struggled with and that I have
dealt with in my life and I'm so glad
that none of my attempts were successful
I'm so happy that I'm here sometimes
when you're in this headspace you can be
deaf to hearing people talk about who
you are as a person because all you care
about is your appearance and how you
look and it's easier said than done to
say that you shouldn't focus on that but
it's true and if you look at the people
around you people will believe that
you're beautiful for who you are and
ending your life just is not the answer
at all I was sexually molested by
another cost me about four years ago and
I still can't find the courage to tell
my parents even if this happened four
years ago I still feel guilty for
everything that happened I was molested
growing up and so I know that there is a
lot of shame that you can carry but the
longer that you hold that in and you
don't talk to someone about that that
guilt and that shame it's going to
consume you even if you feel like you're
managing it okay it can turn into
anxiety you can haunt you in the night
and you have to talk to somebody about
that I know that there's a lot of fear
especially about being believed and how
people will react but like I believe you
and it isn't not your fault whenever my
parents compared me to other kids
because of how much better they are I
think of wanting to vanish a runaway
because they deserve a better child okay
I should read this all outside
I believe my transitioning best friend
until he killed himself after he died I
felt terrible
I couldn't sleep couldn't eat and to
this day carry the burden of his death
on my shoulders I regret it but I never
told anyone
it started in seventh grade I was
bullied extremely insecure simply just
not happy
I had been cutting starving whatever I
could do to punish myself for being me
reminds me of my past way before I was
even born the doctors had told my
parents that did childhood he has a 5%
chance of survival and throughout those
surgeries I ended up having so many
scars all over my body and they told me
you know Janice
those are your battle scars you know
they're beautiful they're amazing and
you should be proud of them when I went
into kindergarten went into elementary
school my first nickname was broken doll
second one being Frankenstein's monster
because of that I became bulimic for a
few months I cut my arm a few times I
just kept punishing myself I kept on
pressuring myself to be this perfect
person no matter the cost
I realized what I was doing was wrong I
realized that the image that my parents
wanted me in my head of myself was
broken and shattered and thrown away by
myself as my parents said my scars are
beautiful I'm beautiful
everyone is me just exactly as they were
meant to be there's other ways to
release any emotion or pain I journal I
go on little adventures by myself
listening to music singing when no one's
around crying is one of the biggest ones
you won't be 13 forever your
relationship will change with your
parents their relationship with
themselves and with their own traumas
will change and adapt they're humans
they're superhuman often to a fault and
they care about you and they're trying
being okay with who you are is the most
important thing and then feeling
appreciated by those around you
comes should come second it shouldn't be
first a lot of the people that seem like
they have it all figured out probably
don't so just be patient with yourself
and
just keep doing things that you enjoy
and discovering who you are and know
that it might take time and that you can
go at your own pace it doesn't matter
where you're at right now it's your
journey it's not anyone else's thank you
to our brave cast who read and responded
secrets and to all the brave folks who
submitted secrets don't forget to visit
our shop we're running out of items as
we speak and follow us on Instagram tag
us in your human good gear and most
importantly stay inside stay safe and
take care of one another see you next
time